en el norte de la India en el estado de
utar paradech los 500 habitantes de la
aldea manduci urba se enfrentan
diariamente a un problema
no tienen baños Así que todos los días
camblage balde en mano tiene que ir a
buscar agua a este pozo antes de ir a
hacer sus necesidades en los campos
cercanos porque de los 12 baños que hay
en esta aldea ninguno se puede usar
muchos de ellos están fuera de servicio
algunos no tienen puertas algunos no
tienen tasas otros ni siquiera tienen
techo entonces Cómo podemos utilizarlos
En este estado
al igual que camblage el 19% de la
población India no tiene acceso a
servicios de saneamiento según una
encuesta del Ministerio de salud y
bienestar familiar publicada en marzo es
decir más de 260 millones de personas no
obstante en cuanto fue elegido el Primer
Ministro narendramody prometió que esto
no volvería a suceder en 2014 en un
discurso a la nación lanzó la misión
barat que significa India limpia en
hindi el objetivo era erradicar la
defecación al aire libre mediante la
construcción de baños si podemos llegar
a Marte con la menor cantidad de gastos
porque no podemos limpiar nuestras
calles y barrios
el gobierno había prometido construir
111 millones de baños en cinco años e
invertir 20 mil millones de euros en
2019 narendramody incluso llegó a
anunciar que el país se había Librado de
la defecación al aire libre pero ocho
años después del lanzamiento de Swat
barat el objetivo parece estar lejos de
ser alcanzado
Nueva Delhi se ha beneficiado de este
programa pero no siempre es fácil saber
dónde están las instalaciones sanitarias
en esta ciudad de 25 millones de
habitantes
el gobierno se asoció entonces con el
gigante tecnológico estadounidense
Google para permitir su localización
cuando Busco baños públicos cerca de mí
se abre la página de la misión Swatch
barat que muestra donde estamos se llama
Misión Swatch barat pueden verla
es uno de los portavoces del partido en
el poder el pjp este exconsejero
Regional de teli hizo construir estos
baños públicos en su circunscripción en
el occidente de la capital él también
dice que ya nadie hace sus necesidades
al aire libre en la India
todo el país apoya actualmente esta
iniciativa de todo corazón
porque era un problema histórico y el
señor modi logró resolverlo
Sin embargo a pocos kilómetros de allí
algunos habitantes Siguen sin tener
acceso a baños
en el suroriente de Nueva Delhi Jazmín
abdulá una doctora acude Todas las
semanas a tratar a los niños de este
barrio marginal
aquí 400 personas viven sin agua
corriente sin electricidad en
condiciones de vida muy precarias y
peligrosas para la salud de todos la
doctora Jazmín atiende a doce niños con
diarrea cada semana debido a la falta de
baños aquel día un niño desnutrido y
débil llamó su atención
el diagnóstico es rápido El pequeño está
deshidratado y sufre de diarrea
y se ven todas esas moscas e insectos
que infectan su comida es también
infecta el agua que beben por eso está
enfermo el niño está deshidratado
anímico y desnutrido crecimiento se ve
frenado la falta de infraestructuras
lleva a la defecación al aire libre y
por lo tanto a la contaminación del agua
lo que provoca enfermedades como la
diarrea Según la OMS 110.000 niños
menores de 5 años mueren cada año en
India la falta de baños es un problema
de salud pública que también plantea la
cuestión de la inseguridad especialmente
para las mujeres de vuelta en el estado
de eutanatech el pueblo de kampaura con
mil habitantes pero sin baños a su
disposición Nadie puede usarlos no hay
nada no hay tasas ni agua ni agujeros
nada así que las mujeres del pueblo se
ven obligadas a caminar 2 km para hacer
sus necesidades es muy difícil las
chicas no salen a los campos por la
noche porque tienen miedo muchos hombres
malos rondan por ahí
es muy lejos cómo van a ir según un
estudio del centro indio de
investigación de asuntos urbanos el 50%
de las mujeres sufren estrés mental
debido a la defecación al aire libre en
la India
a mil kilómetros de distancia en la
ciudad de Pool en el centro del país
ulka salcar iraquí tuvieron la idea de
crear este baño rodante solo para
mujeres lanzado en 2016 y financiado con
fondos privados hay 12 buses como este
en la ciudad están equipados con
letrinas y productos sanitarios todas
las mujeres de la ciudad pueden
utilizarlos a diario estoy convencida de
que es una solución para reducir la
edificación al aire libre en la India la
idea no es ofrecer unos baños lujosos o
carros sino unos baños limpios e
higiénicos y un espacio familiar y
seguro para que las mujeres puedan venir
a usar estos baños cómodamente
a pesar de ser la quinta economía más
grande del mundo el acceso a los baños
sigue siendo un reto para la India